scientific progress is about pushing the
boundaries of what we know about how the
world works this happens by looking at
data from experiments experiments are
designed to test the hypothesis and
either support or reject it
before you begin an experiment you have
to think through the possible outcomes
and what they might mean however these
new discoveries are only meaningful if
we make sure we do a good experiment
let's talk about how to choose a good
experimental question design a good
experiment acquire and analyze the data
properly and why repetition is so
important
if we design bad experiments we
mistakenly might end up thinking that
just because we are observing two things
together like one you carry an umbrella
in your bag and two it starts raining on
your walk that one of those things is
causing the other you are causing it to
rain on your walk by carrying an
umbrella in your back
the important first step is to choose a
particular question we're eager to
answer let's pick a totally crazy
question if people do five jumping jacks
as soon as they get out of bed in the
morning will their hair turn purple
there are a few key things we must think
about first we need to clarify how we
plan to test the question
we will need a group of people who will
do jumping jacks but it's also essential
to have a group of people who do a
different exercise say five sit-ups
and finally a group of people doing no
exercise at all the control group
then we can be sure that any effect that
we do see on hair color is not due to
doing any type of exercise jumping jacks
or sit-ups but is definitely due to the
jumping jacks specifically
we want to make sure there's only one
difference between the groups
secondly we need to think about which
population we're testing
it's often impossible to assess the
whole population for instance every
person in the world or every person with
a specific feature you're interested in
because it's too expensive and time
consuming
so instead we assess a smaller sample
one problem is that in biology there's a
lot of natural variability
if the experiment is not large enough
for example three people in each group
there is a high likelihood that the
wrong conclusions will be drawn because
our experimental groups may not properly
represent the whole population
statistics can help by giving us tools
to calculate the minimum size that our
sample should be this can often be
hundreds of people
we will also now plan how to analyze the
experimental data after collection
so we've got the experiment planned out
we have the question population type and
size and data analysis plan and we are
ready to go
there are a few key things to remember
while doing the experiment and acquiring
the data
the first is randomization if we put all
the blonde people in one group and all
the brunettes in the other any changes
we see might be due to differences in
hair color at the start of the
experiment rather than the exercise
randomization solves this issue which
means allocating whether someone should
be in the test or control group in a
random way
the second is blinding this means that
both the participants and the
experimenters don't know who is in which
group where possible
in this case it's pretty tricky as you
can't hide from the participants which
exercise they are doing but once the
data has been acquired it can be labeled
in a way that means the groups are
hidden to those doing analysis
humans are very susceptible to bias
conscious or unconscious so if the
experimenters know which group is doing
which exercise they might assess the
final hair color of the people in the
jumping jacks group as more purple even
if it is not
finally the experiment should be
repeated by the original experimenters
and others around the world to confirm
the results are not random chance
so remember when designing an experiment
you need a good question elegant
experimental design with a control group
to carefully choose how many and which
people you will include and what data to
collect sensible analyzes and
replication
there could be very serious consequences
if these concepts are not implemented if
decisions on new drugs or diagnostic
tests are made using experimental data
that haven't properly tested the
hypotheses patients lives can be
affected
elegantly designed appropriately
controlled experiments on the other hand
can provide valuable contributions in
our quest to better understand the world
[Music]